Hey everyone, my name is Martin Cousins.
I'm going to be your presenter for this final session of 5
for Introduction to Unreal Engine 5 Programmers.
And in this final session, we're going to talk about UMG
or Unreal Motion Graphics for Unreal 5.5.
Congratulations to anyone who's been with us
for all five of these sessions
because they're racking up well over 10 hours of content
at this point.
But let's get started.
This one's a little bit shorter than the others,
so it's a kind of smaller little digestif
at the end of the whole process.
So what are we going to cover today?
We're going to talk about UWidgets, UserWidgets,
the Blueprint Editor, widget animations,
no variable functions, special UProperty specifiers
that pertains specifically to UMG, the widget component,
and the interaction component.
And last of all, a little example of some UMG
and possibly some hints and tips and further reading
for anyone who's interested.